わーきついな、下の廊下とかもだめっしょ？
ねぇ、な、確かに
厳しいな
いやぁ、じゃこの部屋と、
外の、そこだけ気を付けて撮ります
分かりました、じゃあちょっと家のきれいなところだけ
えっ、座敷でとってもいい？
分かった
許可頂きました
ついに来た
ようやく撮影場所を確保しました
はじめしゃちょーです
あのねぇ、あっくしゃみ
ハウッ、フゥゥゥーーー！
あのね、僕んちは
すごいYoutuberに非協力的なんですよ
僕が実家に帰ってきても
母ちゃんから、「家で動画とるな」
「家の外でも動画とるな」
「部屋の中だけで動画撮れ」
そんな状況で
クリエイティブな動画撮れないと思うんすよ
おれは実家に帰ってきても
動画を取るスペースすらない
けどね、今何とかちょっと話し合って
じいちゃんには、とりあえずこの座敷
この座敷で撮影していいよっていうのと
マミーにも何とか説得して
外でも撮っていいという許可を頂きました
バッチリだぜ！
肩身が狭いね、Youtuber
この僕の家では
ま、とりあえずこの座敷と
俺の部屋と、外では動画を撮っていいといわれたので
ま、せっかく実家にいるしね
家族もみんないるんで
ちょっと、僕へのちょっと家族愛を一回確かめてみたいと思いまして
やっぱ僕もしばらく静岡にいてね、やっぱ
みんな僕の事をちょっともう好きじゃないかもしれない
本当の家族愛を確かめるために
僕は今から外で↴
外で倒れてるんで
果たして誰が、家族の誰が僕を助けに来てくれるか
心配になるとすぐ駆け寄ってきてくれると思うんで
誰が助けてくれるかちょっと、検証してみようと思います
いい家に生まれてきたと僕は思ってるんで
家族愛をもう一回ちょっと、ちゃんと確認してみようと思います
では行こう
家のお庭に来ました
ここで今から寝っころがる
じゃねーや
今からここで倒れるんで
家族の誰が助けてくれるか
てか、心配してくれるか
家がそこだから、僕が倒れるとすぐわかると思うんで
果たして僕の家族の誰が、僕を気遣ってくれるか
肩身が狭い
あぁ
あ゛あ
ああ゛ぁ
ばーちゃん！
ばーちゃぁん！
助けて
じいちゃんが家から
ニヤニヤしてこっちを見てる